I think this is true are you the guy
responsible for getting slash and Axl
talking again and back into the band
Guns and Roses are you behind that or
not I'm sure I'm not solely but I did
meet Axl and a couple of clubs a year
ago and two years ago and three years
ago and I bump into him and I had that
talk and we had his words what did you
say to Axl I said you need to get the
[ __ ] back together again soon because
every we all miss you same thing someone
said to me when Joe and I were fighting
would you mind doing this for Led
Zeppelin get Jimmy Page and Robert Plant
back together that's right
when I went and played with them while I
was in outs with Aerosmith I got a
chance I got a I got a call from
Peterman she was managing Jimmy Page he
said look those guys that were
rehearsing would you like to go over and
rehearse with him I went hmm
I mean without Robert Plant there
without Robert Plant Wow and I went I
went into a studio and the four of us
played and we had on drums Bonzo's Jason
Jason
it was [ __ ] you know and you know I
know by the way Jason Bonham there's a
terrific [ __ ] drawn believable and
and and so when you say you got together
this was an England I was you say the
music was fantastic
what happened we did we did all that did
you record it I'm sure someone did why
is that not Spence knocked out because
it was - it was to see if it was a bunch
of things going it was experimental you
needed the safety of knowing that this
meant get out yeah so did you turn to
Jimmy Page afterwards good this was
[ __ ] great I did and and I said I
said I would I will gladly do something
you know with you guys any time call me
if I'm on tour over there and I'll do
three in a row just to go play with him
saying absolutely but I can't do like a
Coverdale page I can't do a Tyler page I
can't do that I told him he's angry as I
was at ariseth I still said I'm in a
band that's as relevant as Led Zeppelin
right you guys aren't too
it's a shame you should be but Robert
you know is I'm now it took me a lot of
years to get over my anger that he
didn't do that he is such a great artist
yes that he's gone he's taken his voice
and gone in so many different directions
and I love you do love it I love do you
like how Robert goes off and works with
a banjo player yeah okay and he's got
this band and his a song shed I can't
think of it right I know I saw him do it
on TV somewhere oh man it was very good
it's but but but what it's like it
wouldn't it be great if he got together
but he oh he did yeah he did it was yeah
you know keep in mind this is my humble
opinion and I get angry about it because
I am in a rock band and I do sing and I
know what we do to people